SHEILA BOWMAN: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Sheila Bowman.
I'm with the Monterey Bay
Aquarium Seafood Watch program.
We're extremely pleased to
be here and have a chance
to thank you, but also
to meet each one of you
Googlers, and, of course,
hopefully encourage you
and invite you to join us down
at the Monterey Bay Aquarium,
when you have free time.
All the programs that we do
really depend on great folks
like you coming in
and supporting us.
And one of our programs
that we're especially here
to talk about today is, of
course, our sustainable seafood
program.
And I'm going to
take this opportunity
to welcome and introduce to
those who don't know Chef Rick
Moonen, who's come to us this
morning from Las Vegas, where
he has two successful
restaurants.
And really, beyond
that, I think everyone
who knows Rick knows he
has a world of experience
beyond that, from TV--
"Top Chef Masters" program.
He travels the
world-- in my opinion
is the foremost chef who is
speaking out on sustainable
seafood issues, educating
himself, engaging, really,
at the level of fish farmers
who don't know how to improve
and want to improve, all the
way through to these premium
products.
The folks who have made
this conversion, who
have done great work, who
are providing sustainable
seafood-- helping promote
them, so that all of us
can enjoy this great
fish that's come so far.
And in so many cases, we have
environmental heroes out there,
where we can support them and
still enjoy delicious food.
So I think I'm going to just
go ahead and turn things over
to Rick, 'cause I know he's
got to get the lentils started.
So please, everybody--
Seafood Watch spokesperson,
and my good friend, Rick Moonen.
RICK MOONEN: Thanks,
Sheila, that's great.
[APPLAUSE]
What a tremendous
privilege, to be
able to be standing in
front of all of you.
Just because-- not only just
of the mentality of the Google
campus-- and Google world,
I might as well say,
but it's your generation.
It's you.
You are the thinkers.
You are the future.
I've been focused
on sustainability
for my entire career.
I graduated culinary
school in the '70s.
1978.
First in my class.
Yay!
But I worked with some great
chefs that instilled in me
an integrity, a
respect, a connection,
and an understanding
about our environment.
Healthy environment
equals healthy food.
Better, healthy environment
makes tasty, delicious,
nutritious, real food.
And the biggest problem,
today, that we're faced-- well,
not the biggest-- but one
of them-- one of many,
unfortunately-- is that
the food that we consume
is ofttimes so processed
that our bodies don't even
see it as food anymore.
It doesn't recognize it.
And that's when immunity
systems start to break down,
and all kinds of stuff happens.
That's a whole nother
topic of discussion.
But it's just something
I want to open up,
because real food
equals healthy-- health.
You're going to be healthy.
Every atom of your
body is a result
of something you've
consumed or something
you've come in contact with.
So let's be a little bit
more connected to that food--
to that source.
And that's really about
the responsibility
of how I define sustainability.
Sustaining, keeping--
making sure there's
enough for tomorrow,
for tomorrow's dinner,
for the next generation--
your children,
yourselves, and everything
else, going on down the line.
Without putting our toys
away at the end of the night,
we're not going to
be able to have them
tomorrow to play with.
Right?
It's pretty simple.
So I'm going to do that through
a cooking demonstration.
But really, the
opportunity is to have
this ongoing discussion.
And if I can change
the way you think,
a little bit, today,
then I've succeeded.
If I can connect you to a
great source of information
to help you along, as you're,
like, I got a little bit of it,
but I need more,
then we're going
to talk about Seafood Watch,
and what they've done,
and what they do
every single day.
They've got a team
of people in Monterey
that are connecting to a
crazy network of scientists,
environmental groups, people
that are-- government-- that
are measuring and taking census
of different species of fish
and stuff.
Measuring their potential
to be able to reproduce
enough to produce what we
want for the following year.
A lot goes into this.
And I'm not here to
scare you about it.
But I hope that
you'll be motivated
to know more about your
food at the end of this.
Jeez!
I didn't know that!
All right!
Now I know more.
So let's get the
lentils started.
Anyway, what I'm going
to show you today
is I'm choosing a-- OK, so how
do I define sustainability?
We're going to do that
when the lentils start.
Because these lentils-- brown
or green lentils are the lentils
that you want to work with.
All those other colored
lentils are real pretty,
but they turn to mush.
They just do.
So I'm just going to put some
cold water on some dry lentils.
You don't have to presoak them.
It's not necessarily
a requirement.
As a matter of fact, I never do.
I just put cold water on the
fire, bring it up slowly,
simmer it very, very gently.
And then, towards the end,
I'll season it with salt.
If you salt it in
the very beginning,
it has a tendency to
take longer to cook,
be more uneven, et cetera.
So that's Lentils 101.
Yay.
We got that out of the way.
Another thing, because I am
in love with Moroccan places,
right now.
Indian spices.
I think-- what's the movie? "100
Foot Journey," or something?
What is it called?
How many people have seen that?
It's a cool movie.
I mean, the coolest
part of it was
when the guy pulled out this box
of jars, of mixtures and spices
from his mother.
He's like-- [SNIFF].
And the guy ended up, you know,
with a three-star Michelin
restaurant.
That blew my mind.
It's that depth of flavor
that we're kind of going for.
It's the new
palette of intrigue.
It's the depth-- the smell--
turmeric-- ooh, really good!
Turmeric is good because
it's anti-inflammatory
and it helps get rid
of all the pains.
Food does that.
Food can and always
will do that.
It'll help solve 90% of the
concerns and health issues.
My opinion, OK.
So how do we go about that?
Take everything that
starts with a C,
in your whole spice counter,
and that's pretty much what
you're going to end up with.
Coriander.
Coriander seeds.
Also, if you planted that
in the ground, what would
it grow up into?
Cilantro.
That's correct.
I'll help you out.
OK.
This is cumin.
Very deep, very
rich, very earthy,
very delic-- um-- widely used.
Many, many different cuisines.
You're going to see it from
Greek, Mediterranean, Indian,
Moroccan.
Cumin.
This begins with an F, so we're
not going to go there yet.
These are cloves-- whole cloves.
Very oily, very deep, lot
of, um-- well, cloves.
You know?
It's what you-- they stick them
in ham when they roast them.
It's got a real
distinctive flavor.
So you only want
a couple of those,
because that's very strong.
This-- cardamom.
Cardamom.
Really, really interesting.
You've got green,
you've got black,
you've got different ones.
There's little seeds inside.
We use the whole
green cardamom when
we're making this
particular spice blend.
And then-- so that's
everything with a C. Coriander,
cumin-- not-- yeah-- coriander,
cumin, cardamom, and cloves.
And then we get some
fennel, because we need
a little F in there, I guess.
Fennel.
You can add cinnamon in there.
I'll often use turmeric--
you can add to it.
And then you're starting to
go into like a curry style.
This isn't so much
like a curry style.
This is going to be
based on some heat.
I want some spice.
So, in order to get those
flavors out of there,
I want to toast it.
So that's why I'm
putting it in a dry pan.
I have it on a medium heat.
And I want to toast them.
Difference between a
piece of white bread,
stick it in this little
machine, push down the thing,
pops out toast.
Big difference; same product.
Kind of the same idea, here.
Right?
You want to get the--
And you're going to start
to smell the aroma--
the aromatics out of it.
So I'm keeping it
simple to five,
but you can put up to 10
different spices in there.
Good base, what I
just showed you.
Lentils are cooking.
And I'm going to get
back to sustainability
while this happens.
This had to start
real soon, because it
takes a little bit of time.
Do not participate in
the activity that brings
a species to an extinction.
So important.
Ecosystem.
Everything works in
conjunction with each other.
Every living thing on
our planet plays a role.
It was put here.
We didn't invent the plants or
any animals that are on here.
They all have a function
that helps the earth
stay healthy and go around.
You would never think
of taking something out
of your car engine-- driving
down the highway and saying,
"Hmm, you know?
I'm just going to
pull something out."
And expect the engine
to run the same.
It would not.
That's ridiculous.
Yet, if we allow something
to fall out of the ecosystem,
then we create an imbalance.
An imbalance, then we
have to try to repair.
You try to repair it,
you overrepair it.
It's oversteering.
It's all over the road.
You can't do it.
Study nature.
Emulate it.
Respect it.
Earth will be healthy.
Environment will be healthy.
We'll be healthy.
OK?
I know I've repeated it.
I'm not going to
bring it up again,
except maybe four more times.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So intriguing spice mix.
Lentils.
I'll explain alternatives
to lentils, too.
You know, a lot of
times, I'll just
do what I call
"cauliflower rice."
You know what that is?
You take a box grater,
you take a whole head
of raw cauliflower, and you
just-- [SCRAPING SOUNDS]
--and just saute
it really quick.
Boom.
Instantaneous,
gluten-free, grain-free,
whatever free you want to
go down-- whatever road
is floating your
boat at that moment.
There's really great vegetables
that help you to do that.
OK.
I want to make, here, a harissa
sauce, or a fiery-hot tomato
sauce.
Because somehow
vinegar-- acidity--
works really, really,
really well with seafood.
Take a piece of fish,
put it in a pan, cook it.
What's the first
thing you need to do?
AUDIENCE: A lemon.
RICK MOONEN: Squeeze
a lemon on it.
It works.
Acidity and fish protein
are just meant to be.
So we've kind of got the
idea of sustainability.
Right?
You know?
Not allowing
something to go bad.
But there's a lot to that.
What does that mean?
It means I encourage you to
learn more about your food.
Ask questions.
Be curious.
The dumbest question
that you could have
is the question
that's not asked.
Because once you ask that
question, for a brief moment,
you may feel awkward, but
then now you know the answer.
So now you're smarter.
You've expanded your base of
knowledge and connectiveness
to the environment, which
is what I highly recommend.
You know?
If you can't grow produce
in your backyard--
which I also recommend-- get
connected through your food.
Right?
OK.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about aquaculture.
Aquaculture.
What's aquaculture?
That's when we're farming fish.
Hmm.
Isn't there enough fish in
the ocean to feed us, anyway?
Why do we need farms?
Well, over half the food from
the ocean that's consumed,
every single day, globally,
comes from a farm now.
[WHISTLE] That's pretty big.
So is aquaculture good or bad?
Show of hands.
Is it good?
How many people think
aquaculture's good?
One.
Don't you raise your hand.
You're going to
influence people!
Right.
Aquaculture has
a bad reputation.
It does.
It has been proven to be
detrimental to our environment
because of the learning curve.
Farming fish is
not something that
has happened hundreds and
hundreds of years ago.
This is decades old.
It's new technology.
A lot of mistakes have
been made in order
to try to keep up with the
booming aquaculture interest.
So the guys that go into fish
farming, 20, 25 years ago,
they didn't know how to deal
with sea lice, or escapes,
or fish-in, fish-out ratio.
They didn't even think about it.
You're raising carnivores.
Carnivores!
Imagine if you bring that
onto land, for a minute.
All right?
We're going to raise carnivores
on land for consumption
in our-- if you go
to a grocery store,
there's only one category of
carnivores that you can buy,
and it's fish.
Because fish eat fish.
And that's no big deal.
But if you're going to be
farm-raising lions for dinner--
right?
We're going to have lions.
I love lion.
Don't you love lion?
Delicious.
You think about how
it's going to be farmed.
Kind of gross.
Kind of weird.
We're going to have to go get
some protein-- animal protein.
Could be your dog, your cat--
anything-- and it's going--
could be rodents.
And that's not cool.
You see?
That gets weird.
So let's pull it into
the category of-- OK,
now, this is-- this is now
getting a little bit toasty.
You can smell it.
You can see the little bit of a
poofiness coming out of there,
from just the haze of heat.
So farming of fish
has had major issues.
But the good news is, big
companies are starting
to do a little bit better.
They're starting to learn how
the fish-in, fish-out ratio--
in other words, because it's
a carnivore, if it takes
five pounds of some
other live fish
to grind up to make Purina
Fish Chow to feed this fish,
in order to have
a farmed product
come out onto our dinner
plate, well, what's the ratio?
If it takes five pounds to
make one pound, not so good.
Even if it's sardines or
something you hate anyway.
Gross.
You can have all the
sardines you want.
Eat 'em all.
Ecchh!
Right?
No.
Because there's a
lot of other things
that you do like that like
sardines, that eat it.
It's necessary.
You want to keep
the sardines happy.
You want them to have
a healthy population.
And I encourage you
to try sardines,
but that's not
today's discussion.
You know, It's about
fish in, fish out.
So they're becoming a lot
more efficient about that.
The feed.
It's a big topic.
There's a lot of
other topics, and I
could talk to you for
two hours about that,
and I only have 35 minutes.
How many minutes
have I got left?
I gotta know how
quickly I have to go.
So aquaculture was,
and for many years
has been, kind of a problem.
Because you put a ton of fish in
a small area of the open ocean.
You put a pen there--
a net, basically--
throw in a bunch of
baby fish, and then you
start to grow them.
But you put a ton
of them in there.
So now you've got this
stressful situation,
because they're kind of like--
it's not a natural environment.
One of them gets sick,
they all get sick.
You have to use antibiotics.
One of them gets a little
thing of some lice on them,
they all get lice.
It's an epidemic.
You've got to use some
chemicals to get rid of them.
The chemicals that
are used to get rid
of lice-- which is
basically a crustacean--
might have a little bit
of an effect, especially
in Maine, where the lobsters
are, because the lobster's just
a big-- you know-- bug, anyway.
So that's really what happens.
We all love it,
but it's the truth.
It's a bug.
SHEILA BOWMAN: But you're
talking about open net pen--
RICK MOONEN: Yep.
Open-net pen--
SHEILA BOWMAN: --aquaculture--
RICK MOONEN: Correct.
SHEILA BOWMAN: --where there
is this farm, with nets.
And so the fish stay in, and
they put the fish in there.
But if they put
the chemicals in,
they float out to the
rest of the environment.
And then what we also
find is, quite often,
a big storm may come through,
and those fish escape.
Right, Rick?
So all of a sudden, you had
three million fish in the farm.
Now you have two and a half
million fish out of the farm,
swimming free.
RICK MOONEN: And they're
competing for the food
that the fish that live in
that neighborhood need to eat.
SHEILA BOWMAN: Right.
RICK MOONEN: Not cool.
It's like busloads
of people moving
into your neighborhood one
day, and all of a sudden,
you're like, what the
hell just happened?
Well, that's what the fish of
a particular area surrounding
a farm-- fish
farm-- are thinking.
I think that's what
they're thinking.
Maybe they're not
thinking at all.
I don't know.
OK.
So this is our
toasted spice mix.
I want to cool it off
just a little bit,
and the we're going just going
to put into a spice blender.
Like one of these
things-- coffee grinder.
But once you put spices into
it, it's then a spice blender.
[LAUGHTER]
Because it'll smell and
have the oils, et cetera,
of the spices in there.
So that just goes inside there.
I recommend that
you cool this off.
Because what'll happen is,
you do it hot, like I'm
about to do it, you really
have a cleaning project
ahead of you.
Because the oils from
the clove kind of
have a tendency to
stick to the walls--
the inner-lining walls of this.
But what I want to do is
I want to pass this around
so you can smell it.
You can get an idea.
Connect with it.
And it smells so much better.
You see that?
It's going to-- watch this.
Oh!
SHEILA BOWMAN: Oh!
RICK MOONEN: Incredible.
OK?
So I'm going to just give
you a little sniffer.
Start here; sniff around.
All right?
[LAUGHTER]
Then you keep that.
This is going to go
inside our sauce.
This is going to go on
the outside of our fish.
We're just going to use
this with reckless abandon,
because that's the whole idea.
OK.
To make the sauce,
let's get this going.
Sheila, feel free
to just jump in
on any conversation you
might want to have here.
SHEILA BOWMAN: Sure.
So I think what
you're saying, Rick,
is that not all aquaculture
is bad these days.
Is there certain
aquaculture that you
think that is pretty great--
that you're supporting?
RICK MOONEN: Oh.
Yeah.
Right now, I'm
looking-- well, OK.
For many, many, many,
many, many years,
I personally am supporting
noncarnivorous fish.
Right?
So you got your tilapia.
You've got your catfish.
[SNORE] Really?
SHEILA BOWMAN: Barramundi.
RICK MOONEN: That's
what I got to work with,
in order to be sustainable?
I gotta work with
these boring fish?
Because they are.
But more and more, there's
more intrigue and interest
in flavor being introduced into
some of the farm-raised fish.
And the ratios to the feed are
becoming a little bit better.
They're more cognizant of the
byproduct that comes out of it,
called "effluent," which is a
beautiful little recipe of fish
poop, dead fish,
and uneaten food.
It's nasty when it hits
the bottom of the ocean
and turns into this suffocating
blanket of death goo.
Bleagh!
Doesn't sound good.
Needs to be treated.
Something-- there's
a lot of protein
and a lot of food in there.
So you get some fish farms
that are going, food; problem.
Let's grow something next to it
that's going to eat that food.
Like nature does.
So they plant kelp next to the
fish farm-- the salmon farm.
And next to the kelp
they put mussels.
All different layers
of the food chain,
working in conjunction to
keep the ocean healthy.
This is something new,
which is kind of scary.
This should have been
the way of the world.
Just watch the way
it happens naturally
and try to emulate it.
But no, we're men.
We're mankind.
And we're going to
force our way into it.
And that's not good.
That's when we run
into a problem.
So that's called Integrated
Multi-Trophic Aquaculture,
IMTA.
All right?
So, like, YMCA?
(SINGING) I-M-T-A!
You got it?
All right.
I gotta look silly, but
now you'll remember.
So what I'm doing here is I'm
just cutting up some shallots.
Big deal.
So this is how you cut shallots.
So integrated multi-trophic
aquaculture-- back
to the subject-- is,
to me, probably one
of the most exciting
prospects of feeding
the planet, as we grow from
seven billion to nine billion.
Right?
We're already having
problems feeding the planet
with seven billion.
How the heck are we going to do
it when we have nine billion?
Not going to be such an
easy thing, if we don't
change the way we're thinking.
And that's why we're having
this discussion, right today.
Because that will
change the world.
That will educate the
planet, and that will help.
And how do we do it
in a big-type way?
Well, let's think,
for instance--
where and what company
might be crucial in getting
that message out-- adopting
and putting it into play?
Compass.
Bon Appetit.
The companies that are
helping to drive what's
going on in large
campuses such as Google,
and other large campuses that
are like-minded, in the world.
Awesome.
But it's not just enough for you
to walk up, get lunch, and walk
away.
You need to connect with
it a little bit more.
You know?
It's not just about
deliciousness--
and I hope it is a lot to
do with just deliciousness--
but it's not just that.
Right.
So we got shallots.
We got garlic.
Basic tomato sauce.
You know?
This is not--
The thing I like about
this tomato sauce--
it's not one of
those sauces that
has to cook for hours
and hours and hours,
in order for it to be good.
So we put a little
bit of olive oil
in the bottom of a saucepan.
"A little bit."
A lot of bit.
And then we add some shallots.
I'm still trying to learn
induction a la Google.
Induction is just a type of
cooking that's not flame.
Right?
It's magnetic, actually,
which is very, very cool.
You have to have the
right metal on it,
in order for it to connect.
So I'm just going to make
a little bit of that.
Shallots and garlic.
I'm going to put them
in at the same time.
Let them sweat.
Just cook slowly,
without browning.
So that's what's
happening there right now.
And we're going to introduce our
spice blend that we just made,
with four Cs and one F.
And this is a-- well,
the sauce calls for harissa.
Harissa is a chili
paste blend that's
usually used in Moroccan food.
It's used in couscous,
very, very often.
Couscous is, you know-- the
couscous and steamed lamb
and vegetables, and
all sorts of stuff.
Can be a little bit bland.
But then, once you add a
little bit of this, bam!
It's like sriracha.
It is, basically-- that's
what this is, actually.
This is sriracha, because
we don't have harissa.
So sriracha is the
harissa of yesterday.
It's the cool harissa today.
So that's what
we're working with.
All right.
So how are we doing on time?
Ooh!
Boy!
That was quick!
All right.
I'm going to start preheating a
pan over on this side, as well.
Because this is what we're
going to saute our trout in.
And I need to get to
the trout in second.
So I might do a couple
of things at once.
I'm going to try
to kick up the heat
on the lentils a little bit.
And just like I
thought, we're probably
not going to have enough time.
But that comes to a simmer, then
lower down to just a lazy boil.
Blub, blub blub.
All right?
Test it in about 15 minutes.
You take a little bit out, put
it on your table and squish it,
bite it.
If it still seems really,
really firm in the middle,
give it another five minutes,
and then you salt it.
Done.
Drain it, lay it out on a
pan to cool off-- just steam.
And then you end up with--
you end up with this.
This is lentils that
have been cooked
in water for about 20 minutes.
And they're just-- you don't
want them to be falling apart,
because you're going
to reheat them.
And I'll show you
how we do that.
OK.
Shallots and garlic have been
sweating for a few minutes.
I'm going to add
some of the harissa.
This is where you figure out--
or sriracha-- how much-- how
spicy do you want it to be?
Eh-- I want it to
have a good kick,
because that's what
I'm feeling today.
You don't want it so hot?
You put a little less in there.
It's not the end of the world.
That's got a little
bit of, um-- I mean,
you can feel the heat
coming up in your face.
That's basically a
chili paste, all right?
Then I want it to have
that Moroccan flavor.
Well, I just happen to have
this little spice mix I just
put together a few minutes ago.
So a good, good,
good pinch of that.
Let that go in and mix in
with your sauteing hot sauce,
shallots, and garlic.
Then we're going to
add some tomatoes.
And a little bit of vinegar.
Vinegar being the acidity
that I want in there,
I want to-- there's
some acidity in tomato.
There's also sweetness
and a little bitterness.
Which is great, because
that's perfect for creating
a balance on your palate.
But you want to add a little
bit extra of the acidity.
So I add some red wine vinegar.
Right?
There we go.
We're going to bring that
up to a little higher heat.
Reduce it just a sec
and give everything
a chance to kind of come
together in the pan.
And then I'm going
to add some tomatoes.
SHEILA BOWMAN: And we're
going to take questions.
So if anyone has a
question, let us know.
But we're also going to
do questions at the end.
But I think a lot's
going on right now.
So does anyone have a question?
A burning, sriracha-style
question, right now?
Or are we all good?
AUDIENCE: Tomatoes that
are crushed from a can?
RICK MOONEN: These
are crushed tomatoes.
I-- personally, I try to stay
away from canned anything,
nowadays.
Canned is not good.
Alzheimer's.
All kinds of stuff.
You know?
And I believe that the stuff
in boxes that you get, now--
Pomi-- P-O-M-I-- it's a brand.
I'm not-- I don't work for Pomi.
It's not-- I'm not
a sponsor of it.
It's not a sponsor of me.
But I just find that
to maybe be the best.
You get Pomi in
those little boxes.
You know, the strained
tomatoes, the crushed tomatoes.
This, I would usually
use just crushed tomatoes
of the Pomi brand.
OK.
So now we've got a little
simmer going on the lentils,
so I'm going to turn
it down a little,
because I just
want it to be lazy.
Just hang out.
Just, like, floating
down the river,
drinking a beer,
on an inner tube.
All right?
Over here, I'm
preheating a pan to saute
the-- I should preheat
this pan, as well,
because I'm going to
end up with no time.
I think I'm really getting
this down to a science, now,
this-- uh-- not really.
SHEILA BOWMAN:
Turning the stove on?
RICK MOONEN: Just as
soon as I said that--
AUDIENCE: With the
spices, do you just
wait until they start to
smell a little fragrant--
RICK MOONEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --and
then they're ready?
RICK MOONEN: Just,
like, lightly toasted.
You don't want to brown
them or blacken them.
That's why I do it
on a low temperature.
I like doing it in cast iron,
because it has a tendency
to be more even heated.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I had a
question on the spices.
RICK MOONEN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So are you
going to add some
more later, to freshen up?
Because sometimes you--
in some cooking, you--
RICK MOONEN: I'm sorry.
What was that?
AUDIENCE: I said
sometimes in cooking,
you freshen up, near the end.
Will you be doing that?
RICK MOONEN: Absolutely.
You're going to taste this.
You're going to
go, you know what?
I don't taste the spices as much
as I would like to. [WHISTLE]
[WHISTLE]
See, recipes are guidelines.
Your palate is different
than my palate.
So is yours.
You know, I like spicier
food, perhaps, than you do.
Add some more.
Add some more heat.
You know, you just need
the building blocks
to make the flavors happen.
And it's really just suggestions
according to what I think.
But at the end of the day,
it's really up to you.
So, yeah, you do refresh.
This is a piece of
aquaculture-farm-raised brook
trout from Idaho.
Very nice.
Right?
You get rainbow trout.
It's got a pinker hue to it.
They all have a decent
amount of omega-3s.
They're all considered
very sustainable--
some more so than others.
There's some trout available
that is completely vegetarian.
Oh, that's good, right?
I don't think that trout can
really be bad, because what
does trout eat, naturally?
Bugs.
Worms.
You know, I don't
think that that's
becoming an endangered
species, at the moment.
So trout is great.
And it's affordable.
You know, I think it's
undervalued, really,
for what it is.
But it's what's
for dinner today.
So I'm going to dry the skin
side a little bit by placing it
down on a paper towel.
And I'm going to dry it
up on top a little bit.
It should have really
no smell to it at all,
because it's a freshwater fish.
All right?
Then I'm going to
season it with salt.
I mean, you can season
it a little bit earlier.
If you season something
that's this kind
of a high-moisture-content
protein-- such as almost
any kind of fish--
with salt, ahead
of time, what's
going to happen is
the salt is going to start
to draw out the moisture.
Not making it dry, but
concentrating its flavor,
firming up the flesh.
The fat doesn't come out,
just the water content does.
So I like to season
things maybe a little
bit ahead, which is almost
like a precure to the fish.
So now I'm going to put some
of the Moroccan spices on this
as well.
That's going to carry the
Moroccan flavor, mostly.
But just a little bit
on the outside of here.
Why not?
All right.
I'm going to trim the
tail just a touch.
And that gets used, in
a kitchen situation,
in all kinds of stuff.
That goes in your chowder.
That goes in your cioppino.
That goes in a
multitude of pastas,
or whatever else that
you might want to have.
OK.
The lentils are still
doing their lazy thing.
I've got my pan
pretty decent heat.
I want to get it
really hot, though.
So while that's
happening, I'm going
to start heating up my lentils.
So, all right.
Let's pretend these lentils
are now 20 minutes in.
Take them, put them
in a colander, right?
I would have lightly salted
them just before doing that.
I would have a pinch of salt
in that pan, then strain them.
Put them out onto a pan
like this to cool off.
I'm just showing this so that
you kind of have a visual.
You know, shake them around.
And just leave them to cool off.
All right?
And then that turns into this.
Now, how am I going to,
um-- this tomato sauce
is pretty close.
This tomato-- the Pomi tomato
has a lot more juice in it.
And that's kind of dry to me.
Right?
So I'm just going to
add a little water.
And I'm going to
pulse it, in a second,
with my little handheld blender.
That's heating up.
That's really hot.
That's good.
All right.
So a slick of oil into the
pan, to keep it from sticking.
Skin side down, because I'm
going to serve the skin.
I want the skin.
The skin gets crispy.
[SIZZLE]
Hear that noise?
That's-- that's like.
I like.
I likee.
That's making me happy.
And you see,
immediately, I do that?
That's to make sure
it's not sticking.
OK?
We're not sticking.
Yay!
Because that's a pain in
the neck when it sticks.
If it sticks, you kind
of leave it for a minute.
Let it form a crust.
Right?
You can even-- if the
fish is so fresh that it
starts to curl up, stop it.
Just come down on it, a
little bit, with a spatula,
to kind of fuse the skin
with the hot surface.
All right?
That fish is going
to cook, well, I'd
say 90% of the way
on the skin side.
I'll flip it over, for a
second, and just call it a day.
While that's cooking, I'm
going to puree my tomato
sauce by just--
SHEILA BOWMAN: So, Rick,
shall we talk a little bit
about fish diversity?
How many people have
had trout before?
Excellent!
Really outstanding.
Have you had it here at work,
or have you mostly-- has
anyone cooked it at home?
Really good.
I think one of things that's
kind of fun about trout
is you can also
do it whole fish.
Kind of stuff it, and that
whole fish preparation.
Super easy, super flavorful.
It's kind of another new
trend in the way people
are looking at fish.
But lots of people are
not familiar with trout.
So what other fish
are you guys eating?
What kind of diversity
is in your diet?
And Rick, I think
one of the things
we know is that salmon, shrimp,
and tuna are our top three
seafoods in this country.
And it's like 80% of the fish
we eat are those three fish.
So one of the things
that we have to know,
when it comes to
sustainability, is
we've got to diversify
our diet, because there's
no way seven billion people can
live on three species of fish
around the world.
So trout's a great add.
Crab's a great add.
We have a new
group of fisheries,
here on the Pacific
coast, which is
all of our rockfish,
petrale sole, sand dabs.
Those are all moved onto
our yellow and green list
at Seafood Watch.
They're great choices.
So I think it's kind of
the era of weird fish.
Sometimes people are calling
it "trash fish"-- fish
that didn't have a
lot of financial value
to fishermen, even two,
three, four years ago.
But nowadays, chefs like
Rick are picking them up,
making them into, like,
real shining-star dishes.
And you start to
see different fish
on menus than just kind
of the old standards.
RICK MOONEN: Step
outside your comfort zone
is what Sheila's saying.
You know, generally
speaking, I think
people eat mostly about three or
four different species of fish,
and that's it.
Eat something that you
haven't eaten before.
Give a break to that species.
We love single species to death.
We just consume them
until they're problematic.
When there's so many other
things that are available.
Chefs are dying to work with a
more diverse pantry or kitchen
or refrigerator--
ocean products.
All right.
Here, this is just water.
Put a pinch of salt in there.
I'm going to shake some butter
into there until it emulsifies.
And then I'm going to
reheat my lentils in there.
And then we're pretty
much ready to rock.
What I'm going to
need is some cilantro,
if you guys got some cilantro
for garnish, in a second.
So you'll notice, as
you're cooking, the sides.
Look at the sides while
something's cooking.
You see the bubbles
happening, there?
That means that
everything's touching
the surface of the pan.
If there's no
bubbles on one side,
it's probably because of it
kind of humped up or something.
So I see that it's
starting to brown.
I see that the sides of it
are starting to turn whiter.
Right?
How do I know if
fish is cooking?
How do I know?
Oh, I'm so scared!
It's so expensive
to cook so quick.
It's going to get dry.
Aaiigh!
No.
Just look at it.
You've cooked an egg.
You've popped an egg into a pan.
You've seen the egg white
go from clear to white.
That's what happens
with protein.
So that's turning
from clear-- which
is kind of the middle,
still-- to white.
So that fish is just about
ready to rock and roll.
I'm just going to flip it over.
Right?
I've got a nice
little light brown.
I'm going to turn it off and
just let the heat of the pan
carry it the rest
of the way through.
I am not worried at all that
that fish is going to overcook.
Well, a little bit.
But not a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So I'm going to bring
this up front here.
I'm going to crank this
up and turn that off.
All right.
Now I'm going to
just start shaking
some butter into this pan.
Right?
This is called a "beurre
monte," or "mounted butter."
You just kind of-- you can
use a whisk, if you want.
Shake the pan.
Just making a real
simple emulsified butter.
I want more.
One more butter.
Butter's good.
Butter's not bad for you.
It's not.
Just ask Julia Child.
Oh, she's dead.
Sorry.
Sorry, Julia!
OK.
I can hear that fish cooking.
It's talking to me.
It wants to come out of the pan.
OK, yes, I hear you.
And the funny thing
about it is, as soon
as you flip over the fish,
the skin is not crispy.
But once it gets a chance to
sit for a minute, I can hear it.
It's kind of-- tick, tick,
tick, tick!-- crispy skin.
I like crispy skin.
Delicious.
Full of nutrition.
Mostly the omega-3 fatty acids
that are so good for our brain,
our body-- every
function of your body--
is located between the
skin and the flesh.
So it's a little, thin layer,
there, generally speaking.
So whenever possible,
whenever you're cool with it,
eat the skin.
Or consume the skin.
So I'm adding the lentils
to this beurre monte--
this emulsified butter.
It's basically just
reheating them.
SHEILA BOWMAN: And sometimes
at the grocery store,
you have to ask for fish
that still has the skin on.
We're very much
into white fillets.
But I know a lot of people are
starting to ask for that, Rick,
because it's kind of fun
to cook and good flavor.
RICK MOONEN: I'm 100%-- I've
been eating skin on fish
forever.
But not everybody-- I find
that plates come back,
and the skin's been pulled
off nicely and placed
onto the side.
So I'm encouraging you to
step outside your comfort
zone, maybe a little bit.
So I'm putting down
this spicy, fiery
hot-- we didn't do something
that's real important.
Obviously tomato.
It's got some good heat.
Great acidity.
Level of Moroccan spices?
You know, what the heck?
I'm feeling a little bit more.
You know?
Why not?
I really want to
prove a point, here.
I want you to
taste those spices.
So put a little bit more.
Push it down the
middle of the plate.
This could be a little smoother.
Doesn't matter.
You know why?
You just turn to people
and go, "That's rustic."
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
And now we get our lentils.
Place them down the center.
Nice and creamy.
SHEILA BOWMAN: So I know
we're in the wrapping-up mode.
We're going to do a few
questions here at the end.
I know that the tastes are
coming along in the area
directly behind us.
Rick has a book.
Is this recipe in the book?
Or something like it?
RICK MOONEN: Um-- I think so.
Pretty sure it's in there.
[LAUGHTER]
SHEILA BOWMAN: Yeah.
We think so.
RICK MOONEN: It is.
SHEILA BOWMAN: So
books will be on sale--
RICK MOONEN: If it's not,
here's my business card.
I'll be glad to send you
a copy of the recipe,
if it's not available today.
And then I put a little
cilantro on top, as a garnish,
just to give it a little
bit of green color.
And the cilantro
works really well.
Cilantro has a cooling
effect on your palate.
Whenever you see something
spicy such as guacamole, salsa,
all that-- that's the reason
cilantro works so well.
And you know what?
It's cilantro two ways, if
you really think about it.
Because in the
Moroccan spice mix
is coriander, which is the
seed that made the cilantro
in the first place.
So there you have a
super simple dish.
A discussion, maybe, of a little
bit of a better understanding
about aquaculture.
"You know, I went
into that room today
thinking aquaculture was bad."
It's not as bad
as it used to be.
There are people that
are doing a great job.
There's people that are
doing a much better job.
And there's some people that
are still doing an OK job.
So what I try to do to
celebrate the great,
recognize the better,
encouraging them to be great,
and hoping that the guys
that aren't doing it
so well either go
out of business
or figure out and
go back on board.
And then we have
widespread solutions
that are pushing us
in the right direction
to a more sustainable world.
We're not eradicating species.
We're closer to our food.
We have a better understanding.
I mean, the discussion
can go on forever.
I mean, it's--
And when it's
wild, see-- there's
overfishing, because
that's technology's ability
to out-fish a species.
They can't keep
up with the hunt.
There's byproducts-- the
by-catch that comes up.
When they're going after one
targeted species in the wild,
other stuff comes up with
it that we're not really
targeting.
So by the time you filter
out everything you wanted,
those fish are dead or dying.
They get pushed
back into the ocean.
What a waste.
What a waste of good protein.
There's aquaculture, the effect
that it has on the environment,
and the effect that it
has on the fish itself.
The fish itself.
Antibiotics.
Chemicals.
You know, all the
things that need
to be added in order to keep it
a healthy and viable investment
for an aquaculture owner.
But there's also
the environment.
The byproduct.
The effluent.
The escapes.
The fish around it.
All the other things that need
to be taken into consideration.
You think, like, really?
Aren't we exhausting this to--
we're beating a dead horse.
Does it really have that
much of an effect on a world
that two thirds of it
plus is covered in water?
Yes, it is.
Yes, it does.
It has a major effect.
We've treated our oceans as our
receptacle for way too long,
expecting perfect food
to come out of it.
Because you can't just
dump all of the junk
that you don't want to deal
with on land into the ocean
and think that it's going
to come out pristine.
So all back, circle
around, put your toys away
at the end of the night.
Put them back in the box.
Put them back on the shelf.
Next day, you take them down.
They're perfect again.
And you can enjoy
great-tasting food.
All right?
SHEILA BOWMAN: So Rick,
how do you choose seafood
that you serve and eat?
RICK MOONEN: How do
I choose seafood?
I use Seafood Watch,
generally speaking,
as my-- I-- here we go.
Look at this.
[LAUGHTER]
SHEILA BOWMAN: That
was a leading question.
RICK MOONEN: I had
a feeling that was.
No, this is the beauty of it.
Seafood Watch-- there's
these little cards--
and outside there's a display.
Please come out and pick one up.
Put it in your wallet.
Talk about it.
It's super simple.
Seafood Watch.
What they do is they have
three categories-- red, orange,
and green.
Green means "best
choice; go for it."
And guess who's done all
the research on overfishing,
habitat destruction, byproduct--
I mean, by-catch, and all that?
Monterey Bay has.
Because they've got
an incredible network
of connections to scientists,
to environmentalists,
to government
organizations, both non-
and government organizations.
All of it gets boiled down
to a red, green, and yellow.
So, green-- you can't get
green, but ask for it.
Yellow's OK, but there's
still some issues with it.
But it's a better
choice than the red.
The red means
[BUZZER SOUND] "avoid.
Avoid, for now."
What do you mean "for now?"
That's why you have an app.
Because at any given
moment, it could change.
Tomorrow.
So you just push
in on-- you search
for "seafood" or "sushi."
You push on that.
You put in your species.
I punch in "trout."
(MUMBLING) T-R-O-U-T.
It's going to tell me
"Don't serve it at Google."
No.
[LAUGHTER]
It's going to say "best
choice." "Best choice."
Basically, trout is
a pretty-- doesn't
leave a heavy footprint.
It's affordable.
It's delicious.
You're about to have a
little bit of a taste of it
as soon as we're
finished over here.
But while that's happening,
download Seafood Watch.
It's a free app.
Why not?
You know?
It's one more cool
thing on your phone,
as you go down the
50 pages of stuff
you got on there, probably.
[LAUGHTER]
But, you know, I've been
talking about this for decades.
In the beginning, it
certainly wasn't very cool.
People were, like,
oh, Moonen, really?
What the hell, now?
You're going to make me take
something else off of my menu?
You're gonna--
It's not that complicated.
It doesn't need to
be that complicated.
You know, when you go
into a gas station,
you're sort of picky
about your octane level,
because you don't want
to mess up your motor.
You know, you pick
the right thing.
Pick the right thing here.
You know?
And food is what
connects us all.
It's the common language
of the entire world.
No matter where I go, I
have a conversation going.
I'm in Greece.
I'm talking about octopus.
How do you cook octopus?
Oh, well-- Next
thing you know, you
get a 20-minute conversation
going on with a cab driver.
So it's really what
makes us who we are.
And it's-- I've seen, over my
35-plus-year career, thus far,
so many changes-- so
many positive changes.
But we're at a critical
state as we grow as a planet.
And too many generations
have distanced themselves
from-- where's the
food coming from?
Is it really good for me?
Is it good for my family?
Is it going to make
me feel better?
Does it taste good?
All right?
And I'm a proponent of
all of those things.
For some reason,
early on in my career,
it was instilled within me.
Download the app.
Become a know-it-all.
Ask questions.
Please ask questions.
When you stand up to that
fish counter, I guarantee,
if you have your app
open, you already
know more than maybe the
guy behind the counter.
Hey-- where's it from?
You know?
And then you'll start
to learn a little bit
about other acronyms of life.
There's millions of
them in this world.
They'll drive you crazy.
MSC is one good one--
Marine Stewardship Council.
Pretty much, if it has
an MSC label on it,
it had to go through this
incredibly rigorous, almost
torturous selection process
to get them to be approved.
So that's usually a pretty
sound, sustainable choice,
when something has MSC on it.
But if you look for the green,
you're doing an amazing job.
You go for yellow, no one's
going to really yell at you,
but keep trying for the green.
Does that answer your question?
SHEILA BOWMAN: That
was a great answer.
RICK MOONEN: What a lead-up.
What a lead-up.
AUDIENCE: We have a
question over here,
so if you want to help me--
AUDIENCE: I think it
was the "LA Times" had
an article about how mislabeled
fish was in restaurants.
When they did the DNA
testing, it was often wrong.
Do you think that
was-- part of the chef?
Part of the suppliers?
RICK MOONEN: Well, it's
a combination of both.
And it's a great
question, because I'm not
going to shirk my
responsibilities
and say as chefs,
it's not our job.
It's the purveyors' job.
It is our job.
It's our job to know.
It's our job to ask.
It's our job to doubt.
And especially because of that.
Great point, actually.
Most fish are mislabeled.
Why?
The darned stuff's
pretty darned--
it's pretty perishable.
It's the most
perishable inventory
you're going to ever try
to deal with in your life.
I decided, why not?
I'll deal with the
hardest-to-keep products.
And it's like a hot potato.
You've got to get rid of it.
Otherwise, it's not
going to be as good.
And I'll do it in the
desert, in the middle
of Las Vegas, Nevada.
And talk about
sustainability, as a message.
Why not?
I like the challenge.
So yeah.
If I'm a purveyor,
and I've got the phone
call from Rick Moonen
going, "Listen, buddy,
I need swordfish.
But I need harpooned
swordfish, because it's
the most sustainable method
of going after swordfish."
And the guy's going to
go "How much do you need?
40 pounds!
Put a hole in that fish.
Make it look like it was a
swordfish that got harpooned.
Yeah, we got harpooned fish!"
They'll sell it to
you all day long.
You have to trust
your purveyors.
You have to trust your
sources, as a chef.
As a consumer going
into a restaurant,
or a consumer going into a
marketplace, open up your app.
Be a know-it-all.
Please be a know-it-all.
Be a pain in the neck.
Mention my name, if you want.
I don't care.
Use me as the bad guy,
because it's not being bad.
Because you're doing something
good for the environment
and yourself.
So it's a win-win situation
when you ask questions.
AUDIENCE: Are there any labels
to avoid or specifically
look for when you're
in the grocery store?
RICK MOONEN: Labels to avoid.
Hmm.
Sheila?
Do you have an answer to that?
I don't want to say-- you know--
there's certain countries that
do--
SHEILA BOWMAN: Well, I think, to
answer your question, you know,
everyone's sustainable
out there today.
Everyone.
So you talk to a purveyor,
and he goes "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's sustainable trout."
So if you're getting that
line, it kind of is a line.
And a lot of our chefs
are, like-- you know,
these suppliers can be
like used-car salesmen.
It's like-- yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah!
It's-- where did
you want it from?
Idaho?
Yeah.
Yeah!
RICK MOONEN: That's the ticket!
Sure!
SHEILA BOWMAN: So
I think what you're
sort of looking at
is, if anyone just
says "sustainable,"
I'm always like-- OK,
they should have
more behind that.
They should be able to
say where it's from.
How it was cut.
What sustainable?
So I think the one I
would most worry about
is this, like, "yeah,
yeah, it's sustainable."
That's what I would worry about.
If you don't have
anything to back it up,
then you're-- that's what
asking questions will do--
add that accountability.
RICK MOONEN: Great
question, though.
Really, there's
no easy solution.
There's no easy answer.
Hopefully, someday,
there will be.
I doubt it.
You're just going
to have to know
where your food comes from.
You're going to have to have
a little bit more knowledge.
And it's fun.
Make it fun.
Don't make it a drudgery.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, chef.
So what are some of your
favorites from the green list
that you think that maybe
we haven't cooked with,
or we haven't tried, that you
would want to recommend to us?
RICK MOONEN: Do you
have a green list handy?
[LAUGHTER]
No, but he's asking
for my favorites.
I love lower-- if you eat lower
on the food chain-- generally
speaking, smaller fish-- you're
doing yourself a world of good.
Because they're fast-growing.
They don't have any
health concerns or issues.
PCBs, Methylmercury--
SHEILA BOWMAN: Arctic char.
RICK MOONEN: Arctic char.
I love Arctic char.
Arctic char is, categorically,
in the trout and salmon family.
So trout and salmon are
really-- they're cousins.
So it's all good stuff.
SHEILA BOWMAN: Striped bass?
RICK MOONEN: Striped
bass from the East Coast.
We're on the West
Coast, so you're not
going to see a lot of that.
SHEILA BOWMAN: Sturgeon?
RICK MOONEN: Wait!
But striped bass, also
known as rockfish--
SHEILA BOWMAN: On
the East Coast.
RICK MOONEN: --on
Rockfish on the West
Coast suddenly--
not suddenly, but recently--
became a sustainable category.
Holy smokes.
That opened up, for me, as
a chef, a list of choices
of 39 different rockfish.
Of 24 different flat fish.
Ling cod.
Dabs.
Sand dabs.
All these things you
probably haven't heard of.
Eat something you
haven't heard of!
In a credible environment.
In here, they're
doing a great job.
Well, I mean, you know, you
don't go for bargain sushi
and then get something
that you've never had,
because that might
be a little scary.
But you definitely want to take
a step outside your comfort
zone and get some flavor.
So anyway, how's the trout?
You're getting a
chance to taste it.
Is it-- did these
guys do a good job?
Chefs?
Good job.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
They're thrilled.
Did that answer your question?
OK, good.
SHEILA BOWMAN: Are we wrapping?
RICK MOONEN: Yeah.
I think we're going
to wrap it up.
Guys, I have
business cards here.
I highly recommend you take
one-- or encourage you to.
You come to Las Vegas,
come and see me.
You have any
questions, email me.
If I don't have the answer, I'll
just send it to Sheila, anyway.
No, but--
SHEILA BOWMAN: Absolutely.
And thank you so much,
Rick, for being here.
I learn something every time
that I'm around this chef.
So it's really exciting.
RICK MOONEN: How to make a mess.
SHEILA BOWMAN: Just can't thank
you enough for coming out here.
Can't thank Google enough
for having us here.
Again, I hope you'll come
down to the aquarium.
Join us.
We have some great
exhibits right now
about octopus and
different things.
Your support brings
chefs like Rick
into the Google kitchen
and other kitchens.
So we thank you.
We really appreciate
all that you do.
So we're going to be
signing books and taking
photos and stuff.
So the fun just goes on.
So thank you all.
RICK MOONEN: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]